thou must return it whence thou came
this land is peaceful its inhabitants
kind but thou does not belong Dark Souls
3 the ashes of arendelle drops on
October 25th and until then I think
you'll be impressed with how much we can
glean from a two minute trailer the
painted world of ariamis was one of the
most intricately designed levels of Dark
Souls one accessed via a painting
protected by the painting Guardians who
have guarded the paintings of our yamas
for so long that their reason for doing
so has long since passed from memory and
Ariana's always was known to be a person
and he created this world with a purpose
its thou not see Y re Armas created this
world the painted world is home to the
unwanted to the exiled and to the
forlorn if you are like us another for
long so
with no place to call your own this
piece of dialogue references two things
first it references the full onset of
Dark Souls 2 which describes the forlorn
invaders as people without a world to
call their own second the other beings
it could be referring to are the core
viens described by the storytellers
staff as wretched beings with no place
to go
sharing tales of the painted world two
forlorn souls so already you're seeing a
lot of characters from previous games
mentioned here and we talked about the
core viens in this video we talked a lot
about velka and her crow symbology in
this one and I expect to see both
related to this boss this giant violent
womanly creature with a shawl of black
feathers in the concept art it's even
tied to a chair nailed to the ground and
in the video it's flagellating itself
while bent over this giant Lord vessel
like Bowl surrounding it flammable
wooden pillars which are reminiscent of
those found in lothric and you probably
just learnt a new word
I know I did flagellation is a religious
practice involving the mortification of
one's own flesh it's this act that seeks
to put to death one sinful nature and it
helps to separate oneself from your
worldly desires this reminds me of the
mask of velka's followers in Dark Souls
1 which and I quote again symbolizes
their separation from worldly desires so
flagellating yourself is very much
related to velka and this boss has the
crow feathers which is also related to
her another slightly more tame example
of mortification of flesh is the
prostration pose which is this pose
where you lower yourself to the ground
submissively and you kneel piously the
character in the trailer he does this
here in the Cathedral of the deep which
leads me to believe that this NPC is
likely the entrance point to the DLC
this man is offering us a
age and red sliver of canvas which is
the exact same color tone as the
painting this girl sits at and as you
know touching the painting in Dark Souls
1 was how we entered it so it looks like
he's offering us a sliver of the
painting also and it makes a great deal
of sense for the painting to be related
to the Cathedral of the deep for it was
oldrich who dreamt up the miracle life
hunt scythe where he envisioned a pale
girl in hiding she'll be pretty obvious
who he envisioned and it's his deacons
who surround the building below yashka
where the original painting was once
contained and it's his Cathedral which
makes the perfect early-game entrance to
the DLC not to mention this sword which
is identical to the candlesticks of the
Deacons a good question for this trailer
is why does the man say I think it's
possible he's talking about us for we
are the unkennel - and we represent the
fact that the fire has been linked so
many times that we are born from the
ashes of the undead who linked it and
perhaps our ash setting foot in the
painted world is a significant event or
perhaps he's just talking about the
actual ashes of aerion delle which is
something we don't know about yet as the
character arrives in the painted world
notice that the place looks to be in
better shape than in Dark Souls 1 hell
the architecture even looks drastically
different the bridge is also unbroken
torches a lit the main building isn't
ruined at all and there's even slivers
of green at the end of the bridge but so
much is identical about this scene
though and it makes me wonder how will
they be putting a twist on this area how
from a story point of view at least do
you justify recycling the same zone my
best guess is that this could be the
painted world of re and L not the world
that re Armas painted later what if we
are exploring the earlier painting
of the world before it crumbled to ashes
and the painting of Ari Armas is of the
ruins it became I just really want to
know what the architecture inside will
look like look at this underground room
for example doesn't it just look like
the place you fought the wheel skeletons
in Dark Souls 1 I could be wrong about
this but they even seems to be the wheel
lever that we turned to rotate the
statue all that time ago in Dark Souls 1
and this isn't a lever that's seen in
any other parts of Dark Souls 3 so but
while we're speculating let's move
towards the old bosses that were
depicted in this trailer at first I
thought that this part of the trailer
with the old bosses was just cinematic
filler I thought that from software
didn't give Namco enough b-roll to make
their trailer but really all of these
bosses are related
literally all are a part of the royal
bloodline in some way a cyrus is husband
to Queen Guinevere who mothered lothric
and Lorien and who is also sister to the
nameless king and sister to gwyndolin
who Aldrich is consuming and apart from
the bloodline stuff the nameless king
would certainly qualify as a forlorn
exile a cyrus appears to have fathered a
dragon crossbreed like Priscilla and
Aldrich of course is the one who dreamt
of the pale girl with life on scythe who
lies in hiding immediately following
these clips is what looks like a short
cutscene based on the camera angle where
a character wearing Korn X's set is
exercised of several yellow soul sprites
in the untended graves curiously his
hand is burning like it does when you
link the fire maybe this is a new ending
it doesn't look like he's casting a
spell but he is wearing Korn X's set so
maybe they're implying that this is
related to pyromancy I'm just rampant
speculative but it's interesting in
terms of gameplay additions this image
confirms the return of the PvP arena as
we see four players face off in the area
we fought the soul of cinder in terms of
new spells you
no I've gone on in the past about how
spells need to be more than just simple
projectiles that do varying amounts of
damage at varying speeds and at least
two of the new spells in the DLC do look
interesting this disk of light boomerang
thing is great because it requires you
to position your character appropriately
to get a hit on the bounce back and this
frost sorcery could be interesting if it
actually slows our opponent and adds an
element of crowd control into the magic
system which I think it's all he needs
so color me tentatively hyped for the
new spells but bear in mind I've never
actually been impressed with the spells
they've added to a Souls game so the
only new weapons scene is this axe with
the firestorm AoE effect there's this
scimitar with a fairly standard spin
webinar and of course the candlestick
sword that may or may not be buffing
itself with a type of colorless flame
also is there going to be a new torch
added with this weapon art looks like it
new enemies include a wolf pack there's
the fly creatures this staghelm warrior
a more deformed version of the crow man
and you might have missed this but in
the Blizzard are the silhouettes of dark
haired tree women with small fires lit
at the ends of their branches and to end
the video I'm going to pose to you what
I think are the biggest curiosities in
the trailer and in the DLC to come first
the identity of this creature I've seen
speculation that it's Guinevere and the
evidence for that is that it's clutching
a giant Lord vessel like structure and
that it makes some sense for Guinevere
to have given up and been drawn into the
painted world I've seen speculation that
it's velka and I've mentioned before
that that holds merit because of the
crow symbology and because of the theme
of self-mortification that's brought up
in the black set what's more likely
though than either of those two I'd say
is that it's some unnamed being a simple
core vien perhaps
and it's even possible that it's a man
not a woman because the official Dark
Souls Facebook page has labeled this as
a man however I'm pretty sure that this
page is run by a simple marketing team
so I'm not going to put too much faith
in their captions second I want to know
who the man is who brings us to this
world is it Ari Armas is Ariane Dell the
female depicted upon the painter's
ladder is this whole world or is it
still Ari amesys and this piece of
narration is interesting then show my
lady flame why does she need to be shown
flame does she want to see our flame so
she can paint a new vision perhaps and
what are the ashes of our E&L in souls
ashes are remains so I'm not too sure
that Ari and elves fate is a happy one
is this Wolf's if it certainly seems
larger than the other wolves look at the
trees for comparison but SIF has no real
connections to this place and most
importantly why does the boss attack us
with Esther soup time will tell and by
the way remember I recently did a lot of
postulating on how I thought the two
most likely themes for the DLC would be
the angels of lothric or the hollows of
lund or and you can see those videos
here but I couldn't be happier that they
seemed to be throwing us a sort of
curveball as usual and they're hitting
us with something we didn't quite expect
to see and it's not too late to talk
about the angels or the hollows this DLC
could still answer some of those
questions maybe some answers about
Guinevere royal family exist in the
painted world or maybe we'll learn about
the significance of Velka through the
crow symbology or something like that so
on October 25th two months from now I
hope you make this channel the place to
be but until then let's get into some
prepare to cry thanks for watching guys